foreign
[Music]
questions
foreign
[Music]
all right
I'm supposed to be facing like this it
was faces I guess I kicked it or
something
[Music]
thank you
come floor
welcome
welcome my name is Karen Miner I am so
glad you're here tonight
um it's Sunday and we are quickly making
our way to Christmas and New Year's and
all that fun stuff
um yeah I have a couple of announcements
things to make sure to make note of tune
into
first of all for our kids we are having
a party at the Kids Table yeah
next week yeah next Sunday the 18th
during the service
we're going to have a Christmas party in
kids ministry so if that pertains to you
what you need to do is bring one pair
of new unwrapped fun kid socks because
you're going to do a gift exchange
with the fun socks so make sure yes
I don't know that's a question for Miss
Brittany
dex's question is
can you choose who you exchange with
which is a great question
um I don't know but you can ask Miss
Brittany and she'll let you know okay
so party at the kids table next Sunday
bring a pair of unwrapped free free fun
I'm tired socks for that and then
secondly our Christmas Eve service is
happening on Christmas Eve uh 4 30 p.m
so note that time is a little different
than our usual five o'clock we're
meeting a little earlier because uh
Pleasant Valley who meets here in the
mornings they're having their Christmas
Eve service at seven o'clock so we want
to make sure to have enough time for
both services so it'll be a great
service we'll have wonderful music we'll
have a candlelight moment a
family-friendly service shorter sermon
and so it's very family friendly we'll
also have the nursery available for the
little little ones so again that is
Christmas Eve 4 30 right here in this
room and then with that said we will not
have service the next day on Christmas
day that's Sunday be with your families
and friends do something fun that Sunday
for Christmas day we will be meeting on
New Year's Day
okay that's a lot to remember but just
remember Christmas Eve and then New
Year's day we'll be having service
sound good all right with that said I
can just hear it in my own voice kind of
that you know that ramp up to the
holidays and it's it's a busy time for a
lot of us for some of us not so busy
people are in different places right now
with the holidays it's not always the
most wonderful time of the year for
people it can stir up grief it can stir
up some family things
um there's just a lot and I just want
you to know that all of that is welcome
here at the table you don't have to
check that at the door you don't have to
pretend like everything's okay
we're human and that is a beautiful
thing in its
sadness grief joy happiness old memories
new memories all of that it's all
welcome here
um and all of it is welcome to to just
offer up to God and ask for God's grace
and peace and hope during that time some
healing whatever is needed so why don't
we take a moment right now just to close
our eyes
take a deep breath
allow yourself to rest
and to be present here
to be present with what is wherever
you're at
[Music]
God thank you for tonight that we get to
be here together here in this room and
online
[Music]
and as we take a moment to still
ourselves
to just be here now set aside the to-do
list and whatever is coming up in the
coming week God help us to
be here now to be with one another to
remember we're not alone
to remember that
you welcome all of our emotions our
stories our struggles our joys
foreign
God help us to remember that you can
orchestrate all of that into a beautiful
picture of your grace and your love and
your hope
so God open our hearts and our minds
I pray that you would bless everyone
right where they're at
with whatever is needed
Joy love peace patience gentleness
kindness goodness
faithfulness and self-control the fruit
of your spirit God
in Jesus name
With A Christmas Carol it's my personal
favorite Oh Holy Night and one of the
lines is a thrill of Hope a weary World
rejoices so I just invite you to open
your hearts to this sing out and let's
enjoy being together tonight
thanks Karen will you guys stand if you
would like
Gary's gonna start us out on this one
Oh Holy Night
the stars are brightly shy
it is a night of our dear saviors
[Music]
till he appeared in the soul felt its
world
the thrill of Hope
the weary World
rejoices for Yonder breaks a new and
glorious
[Music]
oh
here
the angel
voices
Oh no
eyes divine
oh nice
when Christ was born
[Music]
all night
Oh night divine
[Music]
truly he taught us to love one another
his law is love and his gospel is peace
change shall he breaks for the slave is
a
brother
and in his name all the precious
sweet hands of joy
in grateful chorus praise we let all
with
in Us Praise His holy name
Christ is the Lord
oh
Grace
his name for it
is
[Music]
the more
Proclaim he's
power and Glory
Glory
the more broken
feeling
they're more broken
you kiddos are dismissed to go to your
classes and we will see you after
and we're going to move into the prayers
of the people and for those of you who
are maybe joining us for the first time
tonight we're gonna read through this
prayer together out loud and it's kind
of this oral tradition that's been
passed down through Christian history
and after we pray it together we'll
leave some space for you to offer up
something that you're carrying in
tonight maybe someone that's on your
heart or a situation in our world that's
weighing heavily on you and after you
offer their name and we give some time
for the people online who are joining us
to leave their comment then we'll close
out the prayer together and for those of
you who are with us all the time we have
slightly tweaked this prayer with some
things that were on our heart
um after some recent shootings and other
things in our more our larger Community
um so if you're going along with our
normal script and realize wait a second
this is not what we usually say I didn't
want it to catch you off guard then
um but I hope that we can all pray this
kind of in solidarity together
shouldering each other's burdens and
being here as a community for those who
are hurting and in pain around us
let's pray this together
Jesus for this city of Sachse Texas and
for every city and community and all who
live in them we pray to you
for The Good Earth that you have given
us and the wisdom and the will to
conserve it we pray to you for the old
and the sick for the Widow and orphan
for the injured and suffering we pray to
you
for the poor and the oppressed the
unemployed and destitute for prisoners
and captives and all who remember and
care for them we pray to you
for the vulnerable the marginalized and
those unjustly targeted for their gender
sexuality race or other perceived
difference we pray to you
for those experiencing loss loneliness
and disconnection and for those
struggling with mental and emotional
health we pray to you
Lord we know that you love us and that
you hear us so we lift these names and
situations up to you
[Music]
thank you
for the names and the moments that we
have spoken aloud and for those that we
have kept in our hearts
we pray to you that they may have life
and Light
healing and Hope
peace and a deep sense of your presence
amen
[Music]
I love you Lord
for you have delivered me
for you have delivered my soul from them
I will walk in the land of the living my
soul from Death my feet from stumbling I
will walk in the land of the living
foreign
[Music]
my feet from us don't believe I will
walk in the land of the living my soul
from Death my feet from someone
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome
[Music]
hey
foreign
[Music]
yeah
I will call on you as long as I may live
for you have to live in me
I love you Lord
for you have delivered my soul from
death
[Music]
foreign
that you hear or cry that you hear our
plea that you are not far from us
even in this space tonight would we feel
your presence
would we feel your spirit
uplifting us holding Us close
carrying us through
for everyone
[Music]
for everyone but
clean water and bread
a shelter of space
a safe place for growing
for everyone boy
a star overhead
[Music]
will Delight when we are created
of justice and joy
[Music]
compassion and peace yes good will do
light when
create creators of Justice
Justice endure
[Music]
a place at the table
revising the rules
deciding the shed
with wisdom and Grace
dividing the power
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
for gay and for straight
a place in the table
a covenant chair
oh welcome in space
[Music]
[Applause]
passion and peace
[Music]
of Justice
and Justice and jewels
[Music]
foreign
men
thank you God would we create that space
together and would you meet with us here
it's in your name we pray all these
things
thank you guys for singing with us if
y'all would turn to the people around
you and uh welcome them make them feel
at home and then Brett will get us
started on the message
how about that sound volume
champion
all right all right
Grace and peace
good evening it is so good to be with
you all and my name is Brett I'm the
pastor here for those who may not know
and
um yeah it's just uh it's a joy to be
with you all and
um to sing to worship it's just it's a
joy it's like one of my favorite times
in the week of being here with you all
so
um
let's see oh and as always those of you
who are online love you a lot so so glad
you're with us and uh and also a special
welcome to anyone um who's new thank you
thank you so
um we are in well it's the season of
Advent
for churches all over the world and so
our series is uh pretty creative
Advent at the table
so that's our serious title and you know
we didn't feel the need to trick it up
too much you know
um so for those unfamiliar the the
season of Advent in the church it's not
exactly the same as like Christmas or
like a celebration of Christmas it's
really uh it's like the time of
preparation for Christmas so it's kind
of that that season of longing
um for the the arrival of God in the
world
um because the the Latin or the word
Advent comes from the Latin Advent which
means a rifle so really effectively what
this uh this season kind of ends up
being is a chance for for the church to
reflect I mean like the broader church
not just the table
um the church to reflect on kind of all
of the ways that God like has arrived
via the first Christmas and Incarnation
um continues to arrive and show up in
our lives I mean Christ continues to
encounter people through the Holy Spirit
um even later we'll partake of communion
it's like another encounter with Christ
um and will arrive in his fullness at
the end of all things when God is all in
all what's commonly known as like the
second coming of Christ so that's so
it's really it's it's not just you know
Christmas it's it's these kind of themes
of arrival and how God's um kind of
showing up uh in the world and and how
we can be places where God shows up um
which is like where the magic happens
right in our lives I mean it's what's
the point if we're all just kind of here
like singing some nice songs but at the
end of the day like we won an encounter
with God we want to be the place where
others meet God uh and meet Christ so um
anyway that's not right I'm getting all
appreciated you're right here at the
beginning we're just jumping right in
um so the the title of the message now
this week is the package deal and our
scripture is uh it's from the Christmas
story uh Luke chapter 1 verses 39
um through 50 and just for context the
angel has just appeared to Mary Gabriel
appear to marry saying you know you're
going to Bear the Son of God and you're
blessed and highly favored and all that
um and then we kind of pick up the story
there verse 39 it says at that time Mary
got ready
in A hurried to a town in the Hill
Country of Judea where she entered
zachariah's home and greeted Elizabeth
this is a relative of hers when
Elizabeth heard Mary's greeting the baby
left in her womb Elizabeth was also
pregnant with um the child that would be
known later as John the Baptist so this
baby is leaving in her womb Elizabeth
was then filled with the Holy Spirit and
a loud voice she exclaimed blessed are
you among women blessed is the child you
will bear but why am I so favored that
the mother of my Lord should come to me
as soon as the sound of your greeting
reached my ears the baby in my womb
leapt for Joy blessed is she who has
believed that the Lord would fulfill his
promises to her
and then Mary gets started and Mary said
my soul glorifies the Lord my spirit
rejoices in God my savior he has been
mindful of the humble state of his
servant from now on all generations will
call me blessed which by the way has
proven quite true
uh all generations will call me blessed
for the mighty one has done great things
for me holy is his name his Mercy
extends to those who fear Him from
generation to generation and then we
skip down to verse 56 we'll come back to
this later Mary stayed with Elizabeth
for about three months and then returned
home
so I tend to preach on this passage
every year at Adventist I just think
it's so beautiful of course I try not to
just literally repeat the exact same
message that would be cheating
can't you know exactly do that maybe
every like seven years pastors can start
to do that because people forget and
they're just like that was a great
sermon like awesome you heard it seven
years ago you know
um so we're not there yet so no no
repeating from this guy
um but I still I'll use the same passage
I just think it's so wonderful I love
the um kind of the the energy the
um I mean it sounds a little maybe this
is trite like the positivity I mean like
the just this language is so wonderful
right all this language around blessing
and favor and glory and joy I mean it is
it's just so uh so happy so joyous I
mean you have Elizabeth kind of I
imagine them kind of yelling like in a
happy way you know just like yelling at
each other like just so energized so
here's Elizabeth yelling blessed are you
among women blessed is the child you
bear that's verse 42 then Mary's
responding my soul glorifies the Lord
verse 46 my spirit rejoices in God my
savior verse 47 the mighty one has done
great things for me I mean it's just
obvious right Mary is overflowing with
joy and uh so this is no like
you know depressed surrender to God you
know like may it be unto me as you have
said like no no that's it's it's this
kind of ecstatic uh joy-filled surrender
and you know I don't know how that story
like kind of how it might
um
you know hit hit you because especially
if you're kind of newer to the story you
it would be easy to think like well I
mean
of course she's happy uh because
only good things are happening in her
life I mean being visited by an Angel
and you're gonna bear the Son of God and
you know it's like all so whoa yeah
she's happy I mean if I were her I'd be
happy too and I think it's like yes and
no like if you know the the kind of
broader story of what is going on in
that moment um because this isn't
necessarily minutes after
um Gabriel came to her right so I'm
assuming that she's had to travel and
she's had some time to process this and
I'm sure
um
Mary is is starting to process like okay
well this is kind of a lot
right and there's going to be some
implication I mean surely it's starting
to hit her that like yes this is amazing
but also like huh how are certain people
in my life going to take this
and that we know like she's going to
Elizabeth's house
um partly because the angel said
Elizabeth also has had like this Angelic
encounter and she's pregnant and you
know so she's kind of going to like
probably the person who will get it
because presumably
not everyone will right and um I mean so
you kind of have in essence she's maybe
even wondering like will I be a single
like pregnant mother you know in the
first century like there's still kind of
stigma and such around that but 2 000
years ago like a lot and then of course
she's probably questioning like Joseph
hmm how's you know all this gonna go we
know in fact that once um initially when
Mary had the conversation with him he
didn't take it well not well at all he
didn't say like oh of course an angel
appeared you you know he's I mean he was
said the scripture he was going to do it
honorably it said he just had in mind to
divorce her quietly he didn't want to
like you know bring embarrassment to her
um so what Angel has to show up to
Joseph to be like hey just to be clear
she's not lying uh and but but you know
it doesn't say though that for example
an angel appeared to the whole town all
of Nazareth and said hey everyone just
to be clear
right or Mary's parents we have no
record of that I mean maybe but it's not
in the scriptures that the angel
appeared to hey just be clear your
daughter you know not crazy
um so this is like yeah there's a lot
kind of going on here
um in fact we I did want to jump down
and read verse 56 coming back to this
this part where she finds out she's
pregnant and then promptly leaves home
not for a day or two did you catch how
long Mary stayed with Elizabeth for
about three months
and then returned home I don't I've been
around some pregnant women in my life
and they tend not to do this they tend
not to be like I'm pregnant bye everyone
by support system I'm heading out you
know like no
um in lesson here I'm speculating I just
wonder
I wonder how things are
at home
know what I mean now that's all
happening kind of right there very close
to the context of the passage we just
read of course then you know how it
plays out right later we have I mean as
every Pastor on Christmas Eve has
pointed out for thousands of years you
got Mary nine months pregnant taking the
long journey on the back of a donkey to
Bethlehem you know that sounds like fun
and then
um of course she gets there where does
she give birth right it's not like you
think oh somewhere fancy it's the Son of
God of course not right it's like got
the whole stable Barn thing with the
Cockroaches and the mildew and the hey
just like I don't know just not it's
just not prime right and then
um in a way this kind of plays out later
we know then uh King Herod hears that
the child is going to be born this rival
King and so he puts out a death sentence
so now Luke later tells us then Mary and
Joseph leave have to flee basically for
their lives in the life of their child
they go to Egypt and live there as
immigrants for a few years and then as
things play out Scholars speculate that
probably Joseph passed away this is the
last time like we ever hear about him
like Mary shows up later and you'll
remember Christ on the cross looks at
John and says hey take care of my mother
presumably Joseph passed away and we
don't know exactly like when or how or
you see what I'm kind of driving at is I
want to
um I don't know we just we get these
little native cutesy nativity scene
images of Mary and her life of course
everything's going great in her life
that's the mess so I'm not not blessed
and highly favored right can you kind of
see where we go with this in fact I was
thinking about
um all of the these are these are the
Christian hashtags you know that are
coming like kind of popular at times the
hashtag blessed hashtag Bustin highly
favorite if you're really spiritual less
than highly favored
like more biblical uh which of course by
the way is taken literally from a few
verses earlier from this that we read
like it's from the whole Christmas story
that's what Gabriel like says to Mary
blessed you know but the the challenge
is
um I mean I'm not saying you can't use
those hashtags so there's a fine sure
it's because it's true you are a child
of God you're blessed nightly favorite I
guess but the way it it plays out you
know is often like in a very kind of
um surfacey way you know it's like hey
right now everything in my life is going
great
so therefore
bless finale
you know what kind of tracking you know
what I mean like it's it's like
um new promotion at work blessed and
highly favored kid got into gifted and
talented classes again three years in a
row blessed and highly favored you know
it's like this is this is often how
people play so I was imagining like if
Mary were to do
like her real tweets
you know actually of course you could
have had some really positive ones you
know like oh my gosh I just saw an angel
you know there could be some positive
ones but also um maybe there's some like
these kicked out of my parents house
blessed and highly favored
going to live with my sister-in-law
blessed nightly favored
no room at the hospital heading to the
In-laws garage for my birth
[Laughter]
um
see this is I think this is kind of what
we miss is this with this overly Rosy
this overly idealistic of what it means
to be blessed
when I think the truth is something
closer to this blessings and what we
might call burdens
actually come as a package deal in our
life
um in other words there's like good news
and challenging news for us here the
good news is you are blessed I am
blessed and that's true right like we
all know we if we aren't which I'm not
we we feel like we should be keeping a
gratitude journal of some sort you know
what I mean it's just like yes we we
should be writing down our blessings and
thanking God and being grateful right so
it's true we are blessed we are highly
favored that's all true
but what we often miss is like the other
side of the blessings you know sort of
the parts no one ever talks about
um and often
it can kind of make us start to wonder
like once the challenges come the
burdens come then we start to really
question wait wait wait a second
maybe I'm really not blessed after all
maybe I'm not really highly favored
after all like this isn't playing out
the way
um the way I envisioned I'm thinking um
like in other words
we get the the it's really probably a
better word here would be responsibility
side although that doesn't rhyme so I
couldn't use it blessings and burdens
not blessings and responsibilities but
in essence that's really what I'm
getting at right it's it's that side
comes but we we feel like
um it shouldn't like I was thinking for
example
um Mary of course in our story she had a
baby
that's beautiful isn't it
that's a blessing
right I mean come on some yes right it
is that's true but babies are huge
blessing also
at the same time babies are kind of a
lot
you know I mean like you had a child
they're like oh my gosh I didn't I did
not know I did not know what I signed up
for I didn't have to bear the child and
I did not know what I signed up for like
oh wow right they're just it's a lot
there's a there's a responsibility
there's a burden there's um
there's something to that blessing
that it's more than just idealized
little
I don't know whatever we imagine right
blessings and burdens come as a package
deal
or um maybe you got like your dream job
you know have you ever prayed for like
the dream job the Breakthrough and
finally you get it and then like within
a month
you're like huh
I don't know about this dream job like
it's kind of just a bunch of work
like I was I heard there was an
interview with a a therapist his name
was Dr Barry Michaels who's on a podcast
and he was sharing um when he was young
he had this like dream of going to
Harvard
like from like I don't know like fifth
grade or something he just was focused
on and he was a committed disciplined
little fellow because
um he worked all through Junior High he
was like Harvard Harvard Harvard high
school Harvard Harvard Harvard applied
got in
Harvard Harvard Harvard and he was so
excited he went to orientation he's like
oh my gosh here I am
and he said he finished the first week
at Harvard
and went into a mild depression
because he realized that when you go to
Harvard you mostly just do school work
and can you see where it's like I mean
yeah I expected that but kind of not
you know what I mean like it's because
we we play this thing up that's what the
blessed life looks that's what the dream
you know what I mean we play it up but
the truth is blessings
and burdens and challenges and
responsibilities like it it all comes
together and I'm not trying to depress
you I'm not trying to say like yeah so
let's all just be sad you know and
complain no I'm saying these can both be
true at the same time you know I was
thinking often or um also of another
example would be like long term like
either marriage or long-term romantic
relationships you know you like get into
the relationship and of course it's like
all blessings at the beginning
you know and then you know keep
journeying long enough and it's like oh
okay well
this is harder than I thought you know
right can I y'all are quiet but I see
you quietly kind of laughing all right
so at least some of you are tracking
um what's going on there blessings and
burdens uh they always come as a package
deal one way I might sum it up is to say
and when we start to realize that truth
my ego
wants to focus on obsess over all of the
burdens in my life
but what's spiritual maturity spiritual
maturity
um it begins it's basically learning to
start to focus on the blessings
I'm thinking of Mary again who all of
the crap like she's going through and
probably had some inkling of what she
would go through and yet there she is
grounded rejoicing
blessed
blessed and highly favored
now
I'm imagining I want to take a bit of a
right turn in this in this message
because
um
I think messages like this are like I
think they're true
but the challenge becomes uh
it can be overly simplistic
in the sense of you know like we have
really good intentions you know of like
yes
that is so true
I just need to hold on to my blessings I
need to focus on those I need to stop my
complaining like yes I'm going to do
that and the challenge becomes
walk out that door right there and then
those double doors out there
and life
it just eats Us Alive doesn't it I mean
it just kicks it is a little bit of
violent image if I have in my notes I'll
just say it kicks Us in the teeth you
know just like jeez you know we have
ever don't we like we have every good
intention it's just like oh like three
days no probably 24 hours from now
you're like oh
blast and highly favored you know try
and hold on to the Hope
um
and you know that's even that's I think
true for all of us but it's really
compounded if you're struggling with any
sort of um stuff that was in our prayer
earlier you know
um
like mental health stuff depression oh
goodness
you know
that's it's just hard to hold on to the
blessed and highly favored yes focused
on the blessings you know when you're
just it's just like a hundred times
harder I mean it can be done by the you
know just your fingernail like you're
just gritting it out you know I mean
like
um or anxiety or just intense stress or
I don't know everything that's going on
in each of your lives I mean I'm in the
loop on some of the things and there's
some like really hard stuff going on in
people's lives so I was imagining you
know like as I'm writing this I'm
imagining how is this hitting people you
know and
um I was thinking like yeah this is
probably kind of a challenge so
um so what do you do then
you know like what do you do when life
kicks you in the teeth and it's like oh
I can't I can't do this I can't hang on
to my blessings
um what do you do then uh I came across
the documentary a few weeks back I
really adore this documentary um parts
of it are a little weird but overall but
I kind of like weird so y'all get my e
letter you know I like weird all sorts
of weird documentaries and books and
videos and
um
and it's the it's on Netflix right now
it's titled stats have any of you seen
this
uh my sister-in-law uh Melody Brett you
have to watch this it's like right up
your alley and sure enough she was
absolutely right
um so the it's basically it's about a a
therapist and uh named Phil Stutz and he
wanted this is back like 40 years ago
when he started he wanted to give his
clients not just like talk therapy which
can be quite powerful but he also wanted
to give them tools
um like kind of practical things they
could engage you know and um they see
it's really a documentary it's made by
Jonah Hill the the actor comedian
director because this was therapist and
he said oh these things have been so
helpful I want to get the word out to
others you know so
um there's one tool in particular that
Phil stuff that he talked about that I
thought was so incredibly insightful and
he called it
um a tool about your life force
uh this is kind of a term he's using
really just to talk about
um your own like kind of energy
and you know like with people there's
certain folks who just have that kind of
fire maybe even you've been there at
times where you have like that fire
inside that's just like
let's go like here we go you know I mean
like you have the energy for life and
then other times where especially with
anxiety depression stress and you're
just beat
down and you can you know hear a message
like this like yes I'll try but whether
it's illness or anything I mean just
drains your life force
so what do you do then
and uh so he has kind of this this
pyramid and at the top level star you
can barely see because I drop my hand
but um the top it just says um self this
is really about relationship is that
pretty is this fancy
if you see the documentary you'll know
why I did it by hand because actually he
has little cards and he writes
everything out by hand and then gives it
to the client to like remember
um so sorry if you can't barely see it
though uh so at the very top is self at
our fancy diagram here self and um I'm
going to focus more on the last one so
self would just be I think a lot of
spiritual practices
here
um
the second layer is people relationship
to people also
um
it D or increases our life force you
know when you're struggling with like
anxiety depression the tendency is to
pull back from people
at precisely the moment when you most
need them
but it's it's a it's a strange phenomena
we're just like instinctually almost
just ah
but you know you get lunch with someone
and you start to feel better
you know it's like you're a little bit
more energized what I really want to
focus though is on this last one because
it had me thinking in new ways this is
your relationship not to yourself or
other people but to your own body
and I was thinking um in our modern
world it and that's his estimation he
said I think probably in his his
experience maybe 70 80 percent of folks
struggling with this life force thing
um he said it a lot of it comes back to
um relationship to body and specifically
thinking like in the modern world you
know I've reflected on like why the
Bible
for example doesn't talk as much about
this and I should I should name um what
does he mean by relationship to body he
means three things then we'll kind of
unpack these in a second first is like
none of these will be surprising by the
way but um exercise or movement of the
body
um second is like food and nutrition and
then third is um sleep
sleep so exercise
you know this is an interesting one
because it's almost always framed as
somehow like it's like a body image
thing often our culture you know like oh
that that body you know you're you're
not really acceptable enough so you
really need to to
um look better
you know and this is often how we frame
what exercise is about what I loved
about this documentary was how it
reframed it suddenly it's hey I feel
kind of crappy and I would love to feel
less crappy
and so I'm gonna start moving my body
and gain life force and energy from that
you know whether it's at first a walk
around the block or whatever your
preferred thing is you know everyone has
their thing
um start to move and what happens
our life force increases
um second is food nutrition
you know
um I think of eating like what our great
grandparents ate that's usually a good
guide if your great-grandparents
couldn't eat it
we should probably stay away you know
because it just depletes
um our life force um and then third is
um sleep so often man I think we are
probably I have no statistics behind
this but I'll just go ahead and throw
out a an extreme statement it's America
um I think we're probably the most sleep
deprived like culture in the world
I mean you get kind of Western culture
with its technology we've got the bright
lights at night and you know I mean
combined then with just a go go go go go
go go go culture
always on aren't we always on like it's
just exhausting and then we're
constantly thinking how
how can I get away with less sleep how
could I be more productive how could you
know right when actually we're really in
a season where it's like oh my gosh you
probably all need like an extra hour or
two of sleep from what you're getting
you know and if you're in the baby stage
sorry I'm not sure there's if there's
much we can do
um but uh maybe call a friend like I
need a night you know but for the rest
of us like
sleep I and here's why I mentioned
because I think I'm imagining you're
like this sermon has taken a right turn
where are we right now
um here here's where we are uh
I think in in my experience in talking
with people I think not all but many of
folks um spiritual and emotional crises
again not all but I think many of them
actually go back to a crisis of
relationship relationship to self in
people and body
and I think at times we're misreading it
like in other words we think we're
having a crisis with God God why do I
feel this this way you know and um and
actually it's it's these other
relationships will help immensely and
I've just seen it over and over as I've
like met with people
um that this helps in other words kind
of what I'm getting at is the more
energized I feel the more I perceive my
burdens shrinking
and my blessings growing
as though by Magic
you say oh my gosh it is a miracle
Maybe
but sometimes
sometimes it is practical things
and and I think I suspect I don't really
talk enough about these things you know
at church we tend to focus on the top
parts of this of that pyramid self in
people
and that's much where the scriptures
camp out self people self slash God I
would add there
um but body is neglected it is so um all
right with that in mind
as we come to the table
of the Lord tonight as we take in the
body of Christ and the bread uh or as we
take in the body of Christ in the bread
and the blood of Christ
um through the the wine may it be
um maybe a moment where you partake as a
blessed and highly favored person
and maybe you haven't been feeling that
way of late
but I that's the heart posture I want
you to come with like blessed with
challenges
blessed with burdens blessed with
opportunities for growth and
transformation
um that's the heart posture that we
engage tonight with so we practice here
what's called um an Open Table meaning
if you're you're with us tonight and you
want to participate then you just come
right forward no theological beliefs
checking your credentials
um you're just you're welcome to
participate and
um the way we'll kind of do it is we'll
dismiss just kind of we'll just start
row by row kind of we're starting at the
front working our way
um backs that our line doesn't get crazy
long and then finally you're welcome to
just partake whenever you like so you
can take it immediately you can return
to your seat but it'll just kind of be
up to you
um to to actually take the elements when
you would get when you'd like to
so this is the table
not at the church
but of the Lord
and it's made ready for those who love
him and for those who want to love him
more
so come
you who have much faith and you who have
little
you who have been here often and you who
have not been here long
you who have tried to follow
and you who have failed
because it's the Lord Jesus who invites
you
and it's his will that those who want to
meet him should meet him here
come to the table
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
the words of this next song are
um we're getting a sound man signal and
I'm not sure what it is sorry
oh Gary's plug Maybe
thank you
um the words of this next song are ones
that um really are coming from that
passage in the Bible where it says
blessed are the peacemakers blessed are
the Meek
um
blessed are the people that we would not
think are blessed
that God looks at them and says you are
and my friends and I have had some
discussions lately about that whole like
Brett was talking about like the bless
and highly favored hashtags and all of
that and you know how do we Define
blessing and what is blessing and how
can you be blessed and highly favored
one moment whenever things are good and
then the next moment when something bad
happens to you does that mean that God
suddenly isn't blessing your life and he
doesn't love you
um which I don't believe but
um
I love going back to that Passage
and in the Beatitudes and remembering
um
the blessings come in the most
unexpected packages
in the most unexpected people and and
God sees us and he loves us and he's a
part of our stories in both the highs
and the lows he is with us so I hope
that we can enter into this song
together and and find the blessing
wherever you're at tonight
[Music]
foreign
verse that we're going to sing
[Music]
gives you an idea of who this song is
for
[Music]
so if you resonate with
struggling to feel blessed or highly
favored tonight
or if you read through this and you
think
struggling with that if you if you feel
down and out or missing misunderstood
[Music]
less than if you feel like you don't
have a place at the table I invite you
to just let us sing this song over you
tonight
[Music]
and blessed are the ones who do not bear
All The Broken Pieces of their heart
blessed are the tears of all the
[Music]
weary
flowing like a sky a falling stars
siddar the wounded ones in
[Music]
morning
brave enough to show the Lord their
scars
blessed are the hurts that are not
hidden
open to the healing touch of God
the kingdom is yours
hold on a little more this is not the
end
hope is in the Lord keep your eyes on
him
[Music]
even in the face
blessed are the Deeds
[Music]
serving with and guarded gratitude
blessed are the ones who fight for
justice
longing for the god
blessed is the
[Music]
kingdom is yours
the kingdom is yours
foreign
[Music]
hope is in the
Lord keep your eyes on him the kingdom
is yours
oh
hold on a little more this is not the
end
hope is in the Lord keep your eyes on
him
[Music]
oh
and blessed are the ones who suffer
violence
still have strength to love their
enemies
blessed is the faith of those who
persevere enough that they'll they'll
never know to feed foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
is yours
hold on a little more this is not the
end
hope is in the Lord keep your eyes on
him
hold on a little more this is not the
end
hope is in the Lord keep your eyes on
him
[Music]
amen thank you worship team what a gift
ah
thank you so much for being with us you
being here enriches this community
for sure for sure
if you're visiting with us tonight thank
you for being here we would love to
connect with you and just know that you
are here tonight so when you leave if
you could stop at the little itty bitty
wooden table to your right right outside
the store and fill out one of our
visitor cards with your name and contact
information drop it in the Box we'll
reach out to you this week we would love
to do that
also don't forget about the kids
ministry party next Sunday bring fun
socks for the gift exchange yay also
you are not in this alone so if you
would like prayer somebody to talk to a
hug
um I'll be at the back after we're done
would love to talk with you
um lastly how about a benediction to go
into your week with
um if you wouldn't if you're comfortable
doing so you can stand your feet or you
can stay seated whichever you like a
benediction is just a blessing as you go
you can also hold out your hands if you
like and a posture to receive these
words that I believe are true for each
and every one of you
you are a child of God
[Music]
this is true on your best day
and it's true on your worst day
[Music]
so as you go into your week ahead with
its yet to be determined highs and lows
and everything in between
go with the assurance
that you are loved you are worthy and
you are accepted Just As You Are
and go filled with God's Holy Spirit and
the desire to extend these same Gifts of
Grace and love and compassion
to everyone you come in contact with
this week
be blessed have a good week we hope to
see you back here next Sunday good night
[Music]
hold on
this is
[Music]
foreign